أعتقد أن دبي بعد الطمع
قد أصبحت حقًا مدينة عالمية حيث
تجذب
الكثير من الأثرياء الممتد من
الصين إلى موسكو إلى المملكة المتحدة إلى إفريقيا وجميع
أنحاء العالم ، أحتاج الآن إلى التركيز
أكثر على أنني سأقول كثافة أقل لأن
كل هؤلاء  الأشخاص الأثرياء يريدون كثافة أقل ،
أعني أنهم يقومون بعمل رائع من
خلال تقديم
تأشيرات وجوازات سفر ذهبية لتغيير القوانين
قوانين عمل أكثر ودية وأكثر أنت
تعرف اللوائح الودية لكنني أفكر
في الكثافة من وجهة نظري على الرغم من أنني قمت
ببناء أكبر عدد من  أبراج في دبي
أعتقد أننا بحاجة للذهاب إلى ارتفاع منخفض الآن ،
فهل تقبل
أنك أو أنك
جزء من المشكلة التي أوصلتنا إلى هذه
المرحلة وإذا قبلت ذلك ،
فستكون قائدًا للحل
في المستقبل
لا أعتقد أنني كنت جزءًا من مشكلة ،
ولا أعتقد أنهم بدأوا المشكلة ،
فالمدينة كانت صغيرة جدًا ، وتحتاج إلى تطويرها
لتوسيع نطاقها ،
كما لو كان عمرك خمس سنوات ، فأنت بحاجة إلى
تناول الطعام لتصبح  18 ذ  آذان بعمر ستة أقدام وطولها ستة
أقدام لم يكن ذلك خطأً
ولكنك الآن تبلغ من العمر 22 عامًا وقد كبرت ،
ولست بحاجة إلى تناول وجبة دسمة
لزيادة الوزن الذي تعرفه الآن أنك بحاجة إلى
توخي الحذر بشأن طعامك الذي يناسبني.
مثال لذلك قمنا بعمل جيد الآن ، أنا
أتحدث كثيرًا حتى مع السلطة ،
فلنقم بمزيد من الارتفاعات المنخفضة ، المزيد من الرفاهية ،
أتساءل هل أي شخص يستمع إليك ، هل
أي شخص يتفق معك في أنه في الواقع
لديه نقطة
أقل هو أكثر نعم أعني أنظر  نخلة ،
نحن هنا في منزلي في نخلة النخيل به
برج واحد فقط
حسنًا الآن برجان أتلانتس وفي
واحد في المنتصف ، لذا فإن معظمها عبارة عن
منازل وستة مبانٍ من سبعة طوابق حتى
تتمكن من تعيين الأولاد كل ما تعرفه من المرتفعات